tant qu'il y aura un pays dans le monde
où il y aura une épidémie en fait nous
resterons à risques c'est ça le vrai
sujet et il y avait beaucoup de pays il
ya un goûter ce qui m'ennuie dans cette
affaire c'est que au début de la crise
quand nous apprenions parce que nous
avons collectivement a pris il y avait
ce débat sur la chine chinois continuer
à venir en europe et certains disaient
il faut arrêter qu'il vienne au disait
mais non laisser faire et c'est ça a
était probablement une erreur de ne pas
fermer les frontières
le vis-à-vis de pays de hot hot en des
milieux aux épidémies d'intensité
épidémique là c'est pareil
j'ai l'impression qu'on fait les mêmes
erreurs et fermé les frontières me
semble en tout cas lors patriotes
ryanair qui viennent d'inde aujourd'hui
d'amérique pas du tout je pense que les
citoyens français doivent pouvoir
trouver refuge sur le territoire
national mais quand il arrive sur le
territoire il devrait faire l'objet d'un
tracé particulier qu'on puisse savoir où
ils vont leur demander de prendre des
précautions particulières
je ne suis pas certain qu'il y ait des
recommandations qui leur sont faites
quand il arrive sur
l'internationalisation
il faut cesser de disserter sur y
aura-t-il ou pas une deuxième vague
savent faut cesser nous savons
maintenant il faut s'y préparer
on cesse de ce délire quand la
différence parce que mal la différence
est liée au non c'était pas liés il ya
des gens qui ne cessent de disserter en
disant oui moi je crois que ça va
arriver moi je crois que ça ne va pas
arriver en fait on s'en fiche mal la
question même si ça arrive
non est ce que c'est ce qu'on est ce
qu'on est prêt vous savez c'est comme si
vous me disiez va-t-il y avoir un
incendie dans le quartier
peu importe il faut avoir une caserne de
pompiers le masque le lavage des mains
les distances de sécurité
tous ces éléments il ne faut pas se dire
que ce n'est plus nécessaire parce
qu'aujourd'hui il n'y a plus que des
clusters en france et puis dans les
espaces clos les espaces fermés
attention aux grands rassemblements on
sait très bien qu'il suffit d'un super
contaminateur un super campagne
contaminateur dans un espace clos dans
une réunion pour relancer commerce ou un
des sujets de la réforme du système de
santé
ces deux le musclé et de faire en sorte
qu'on ne soit plus à poil c'est demain
quelque chose nous arrive et puis pardon
mais le ségur de la santé même si c'est
beaucoup d'argent encore une fois c'est
l'homme d'opposition ont dit c'est
l'équivalent du mini du du budget annuel
de l'ensemble de
bien sûr on espère milliards à 6
milliards c'est considérable jamais un
tel effort a été fait il faut le
souligner toutefois si on s'en arrête là
on loupe on loupe l'ont loupé la marche
pourquoi parce que le vrai sujet de
l'hôpital mais aussi de la médecine de
ville c'est quoi c'est l'hyper
bureaucratie
c'est la complexité des circuits de
décision c'est la paperasserie qui a
envahi toute la médecine qu'elle soit en
ville à l'hôpital c'est l'incapacité de
l'hôpital de travailler correctement
avec la ville et réciproquement
bref toutes ces barrières qui font que
le système de santé français pour être
beaucoup plus performant
moi je crois que c'est ça aussi le ségur
de la santé j'attends des propositions